madame monsieur bonsoir que la fête
commence le 53e festival de cannes
présidé cette année par luc besson s'est
ouvert sous la pluie une surprise pour
la première fois lionel jospin a gravi
les marches en compagnie de son épouse
et de la ministre de la culture
catherine tasca pendant 11 jours la
croisette va vivre au rythme des
projections et des réceptions les plus
courus en soins cormery nathalie gallet
à cannes il y a les monteurs de marche
professionnels et les autres voici
adriana karembeu dans un numéro très mis
là on aura remarqué le style beaux
dépouillé de christian clavier celui un
peu fouillis des membres du jury et
celui forcément aux officiels adopté par
le premier ministre accompagné de son
épouse et du ministre de la culture
catherine tasca la culture luc besson
président de lille sur 2000 il ya
justement fait allusion lors de la
soirée d'ouverture le premier ministre
c'est un honneur pour moi d'être ce soir
votre président
maintenant laissez moi vous présenter
mon gouvernement dont les membres ont
une particularité unique au monde
ils sont tous à la culture un jury parmi
lequel on reconnaît notamment patrick
modiano jeremy avance
kristin scott thomas et nicole garcia
une cérémonie d'ouverture dont on
retiendra le magnifique ballet signes et
josé montalvo et les images tout aussi
superbe de vattel le film de roland
joffé le 53e festival international est
donc lancée et la fête va battre son
plein sur la croisette pendant 12 ans